la mise en place d'une forme de
ségrégation voilà les mots de ce
restaurateur pour qualifier
l'instauration du passani terre depuis
les annonces des manuels macron lundi
soir hubert de fight ans ne décolère pas
dans son restaurant à blagnac il va
jusqu'à qualifier cette future loi de
scélérate
la pression est quand même phénoménal
elles mêmes disproportionnée 45000 euros
damende un an de prison ferme
faut quand même avouer que on est dans
une folie législatives de faire peur à
tout le monde on se conformera aux lois
même échelle sont un peu scélérates et
même si elles sont difficiles
on gagnera mais on le fera quand même
parce que nous on appelle néanmoins au
civisme de tous à partir de début août
les clients des restaurants mais aussi
leurs salariés devrait donc présenter un
pass sanitaire prouvant qu'ils ont été
vaccinés ou qu'ils ont été testés
négatifs au coc u19 des mesures qui
continue de faire polémique et que le
président de la république justifie par
l'augmentation des contaminations dues
aux variants delta le président de la
branche de restauration l'umih 31 nous
le confesse c'est à contrecoeur qu il
vérifiera le pass annie terre de ses
clients alors on agira comme on pourra
le faire ça veut dire que si on n'est
pas obligé de contrôler moi je ne
contrôleraient pas il est hors de
question que je me que je
je prenne ma place de la police l'état
doit assumer toutes ses décisions
moi si je ne suis pas obligé je ne le
ferai pas plongé dans l'incertitude le
propriétaire du restaurant l'esprit du
sud ouest ne se voit pas refouler ses
clients après les longs mois de
fermeture imposée par la crise sanitaire
et se demande encore comment il va
réussir à imposer ses contrôles à ce
jour moment où je vous parle n'ont pas
cette capacité de police de pouvoir
contrôler donc on devra faire cela en
espérant bien sûr qu'on nous donne de
toutes les modalités le plus rapidement
possible afin qu'on puisse organiser si
l'instauration du passani terre est
considérée comme liberticide par
certains français c'est surtout
l'incertitude et l'inquiétude qui guette
aujourd'hui les professionnels de la
restauration